I like taking risks Silo can I say I'm a
thrill seeker can you imagine a party
that lasts for two weeks straight and
did you know that Margot Robbie actually
improvised her kiss with Brad Pitt the
filming of Babylon certainly was wild so
without further Ado let's party it's
just like keeping up really number one
she saw a chance and she took it
although Margot Robbie would admit that
her movie kiss with Brad wasn't in the
script she apparently thought when else
am I gonna get the chance to kiss Brad
Pitt I'm just gonna go for it that
wasn't the only perk Robbie took
advantage of but more on that soon when
she approached Damien chazelle with the
idea he agreed that it was something her
character would do in fact he thought
the scene worked so well that he'd asked
them to do the take again and what did
Brad think about the improvised kiss you
know what you're after and then you just
let the the spirits take over number two
does Margot Robbie ever get tired
according to her it was important to
have the party atmosphere throughout the
whole film even when Margot wasn't on
set she was still partying but even on
the weekends I was like in Nelly mode I
was like right we're going out we're
partying and why was she doing this well
the way that she explained it I was like
I kind of need it finale like I need her
to never have a minute of quiet never
compose herself just always be like
number three what's the longest you've
ever partied although the party scene
only lasts about 15 minutes in the movie
it apparently took the crew two weeks to
film it the first day was was a bit
shocking like even for me writer
director Damien chazelle explained that
he wanted it to be the party scene and
all party scene but admitted that the
filming of it got pretty wild stating it
did feel like we were in our own little
bubble it's like the outside world was
going by normally but inside it was
1920s debauchery of the highest level
number four think you know what Toby
Maguire's toughest scene was according
to him he had so many nerves on the
first day of filming that he sort of
just exploded in the take he went on to
explain how a producer had told him that
he can bring an energy level of 16 out
of 10. resulting in a performance where
he just exploded in a ball of nerves and
crazy weird Expressions that was not
coherent or consistent immediately after
his take everyone headed to lunch which
Toby described as a really good
interesting and weird lunch number five
can you cry on command Margot Robbie's
character Nelly Leroy is an aspiring
actress who's surprisingly skilled in
crying on command which is something
Margot Robbie can actually do in real
life I had a fair share of practice
Crying On Cue she's apparently gotten so
good at it that she's even able to ask
the director doing it on my left eye or
right eye when asked if she thinks about
anything in particular when she does it
Margot said honestly it sounds so stupid
and derivative but I just think of
something sad number six you're hardly
going to believe the amount of costumes
made by production Babylon has by far
the largest number of actors that I've
ever dressed on a film according to the
costume designer Mary zofrie's there are
7 000 costumes in this movie between
background and 150 speaking Parts
principal cast members had about 15
changes Mary revealed that she had to do
a lot of research because the challenge
was always find some inspiration that's
from the 20s that doesn't look like your
typical twenties that's to me is my most
the most important part of my job is how
do the costumes serve the story number
seven your clothes can say a lot about
you Damien chazelle has spoken on how
the characters largely Define themselves
through what they're wearing especially
people like Nelly Leroy Nellie's all red
outfit is meant to reflect her free
spirit and ambition with the costume
designer describing it as something
she's cobbled together herself like tap
dance and a scarf wrapped around the
waist Nelly comes from nothing and if we
could see that in a costume and great
number eight to go formal or not to go
formal that was the question facing Mary
when it came to designing the Wardrobe
for Brad Pitt's character according to
her my pitch for Jack was that he's such
a big movie star that he's just not
formal he wears a tuxedo to the parties
but other than that we don't see him in
a suit instead we see him wearing a lot
of Cardigans throughout the movie as
well as sweaters that were all knit by
hand I'm a stickler for details like
that number nine a lot of attention went
into recreating Los Angeles of the 1920s
I just wanted to jump into those visuals
production designer Florencia Martin
chose an isolated location in Peru
explaining that it was what Hollywood
and Studios looked like in the silent
film era here an outdoor silent movie
studio was built with six or seven sets
running at all times you're talking
about sets within sets with insets some
filming was also done out of Santa
Clarita Valley in Los Angeles we'd
really tried to to build the world and
show those contrasts throughout number
10 it takes a lot of big sounds to
recreate the drama of the silent film
era Damien chazelle insisted that
Babylon be filled with sounds that feel
almost Larger than Life and so every
actor was given a personal mic so that
several scenes could feature multiple
conversations going on at once it's
almost like Controlled Chaos of sound
not only that but music would often be
played silently through earpieces
allowing the team to set up a bunch of
mics around the set to record a wider
perspective of different sounds we try
to recreate it with some natural sounds
from the scene but building up a rhythm
number 11. the music of Babylon plays an
important role in setting the tone the
film features over two hours of original
music and according to the composer a
huge part of my process in creating the
music for Babylon was Finding unique
musicians to bring it to life it was a
lot more muscular because it was built
on that really like heavy riff based
style of writing this isn't the first
time that Justin will be working with
Damien chazelle either as the two have
previously collaborated on the music for
La La Land number 12. these hairstyles
may not be what you think of as hair
stylist Jamie Lee McIntosh told Allure
when you think of the 20s it's the Bob
and finger waves but chazelle wanted to
stay away from the cliches Margot Robbie
is actually wearing a wig to make her
hair longer and Fuller although the hair
stylist added that it was very important
that the wig fit her well considering a
lot of references she was giving were of
Janice Joplin shaking her head I'm on
the run Marco Lots going on number 13.
the makeup of Babylon came from an
unexpected Source One of the muas
revealed that she didn't want characters
who looked like typical Hollywood stars
and so she drew a lot of inspiration
from mugshots of the time this helped
her find references of real people she
described Nellie's party makeup by
saying yeah I borrowed lipstick from my
neighbor because I needed to get get
into this party number 14 the right cast
is important for any movie Damien
chazelle wanted the experiences of his
characters to be reflected in his cast
which was why he lucked out finding
movie star Brad Pitt to play the movie
star Jack Conrad there's always
something new I'm finding with with new
directors and everyone has their own
language and style for Nelly Leroy
Damien said he wanted someone who was a
movie star but also who has arrived on
the scene recently as well as being
someone who's utterly Fearless he found
his perfect Nelly in Margot Robbie I
kind of love that and um I I get I don't
know I get a real kick out of that it's
an adrenaline rush number 15 Babylon is
inspired by entirely real stories
according to Damien chazelle he was
inspired to write the script by reading
about the Golden Age of Hollywood I
would just find my jaw on the floor you
know all the time he said his goal was
not to sanitize anything revealing that
Jack Conrad is inspired by John Gilbert
Clark Gable and Douglas Fairbanks well
while Nelly Leroy is a mix between
personalities like Clara Beau and Joan
Crawford whether we're talking about
parties on set or the endless hours of
dedication there was never a dull moment
filming Babylon what do you consider to
be the most shocking behind the scenes
detail on this movie make sure to let us
know down in the comments